[Musique]
mais très élégant c'était une grande
chose dans la vie passée on juge souvent
une personne sur son élégance la
première chose qu'on lorsqu'on juge une
personne on voit s'il est bien habillé
c'est l'aspect extérieur voilà cela
jamais et c'est important cet expert cet
aspect extérieur pour un étudiant moi
que pour une femme moines pour une femme
et enfin les professeurs vougy souvent
sur votre aspect extérieur donc vous
avez plutôt intérêt
quelquefois est bien habillé vous pouvez
me dépeindre la mine mana garçon moderne
oui pantalon assez large chemise
américaine c'est-à-dire s'est mise assez
large à petits carreaux enfin allure
négligée ou soigner à non plutôt
négligée l'oeil est assez négligent
jouant avec la mode la modifiant
l'accent tout en la repoussant
mais sans jamais l'ignorer ils font de
leur façon de s'habiller un jeu un jeu
dans lequel ils essaient d'affirmer de
préciser leur personnalité car c'est
bien la personnalité de tous ces jeunes
que l'on découvre à travers leurs goûts
et leurs idées ils soient lycéens
étudiants ou employé
cependant pour beaucoup d'entre eux tout
au moins jusqu'à 18 ans il est très rare
que l'on fasse seul ch à maman vous
accompagne heureusement depuis quelques
années les jeunes ont une mode bien à
eux
elle est obligée de choisir parmi des
modèles conçus en fonction de leurs
goûts
les lycéennes et lycéens qui composent
la clientèle habituelle de ce magasin du
quartier saint-lazare peuvent en entrant
posé sur l'électrophone le disque de
leur choix un disque lié bien sûr ou
jouer à la machine à sous
tout comme dans les films américains
ceci pour bien prouver que l'on est dans
le vent et que la collection l'est
également
quelles doivent être les
caractéristiques de la mode pour qu'elle
vous plaisent à vos jeunes filles il
faut qu'elle s'adapte à nos besoins
c'est à dire pour aller au lycée si bien
que pour sortir c'est l'uniforme de la
jeunesse de kabange
c'est très pratique très confortable moi
j'ai moi pas tellement d'avoir une comme
ça que je trouve fermeture est car c'est
trop dur attaché si moi j'aimerais bien
seulement on n'en veut pas je trouve que
ça fait trop sport ça peut pas se porter
partout mais il me semble que les
modèles que vous présentez sont plutôt
étriqué pour quelles raisons ils ne sont
pas étriqué mais les jeunes nous demande
toujours détail de taille ou dessous
au moins pour rock ça s'ajuste au corps
et c'est la nouvelle mode nouveaux
désirs des jeunes à belle île très
serrée dans les véhicules qu'est ce qui
vous plaît dans ce trench coat ainsi
qu'il a le style
je cherchais quel style justement un
style sport et pratique un style
vraiment peugeot nous y voilà et vous
faites toujours vos actions avec votre
mère toujours pourquoi venez-vous pas
tout seul quel âge avez-vous 17 ans et
qu'est ce que vous faites
je devrais je suis apprentie miroitier
jeux à l'école le ya 17 on ne peut pas
choisir tout seul ses vêtements ont si
j'achète trop excentré que ma mère soit
pas tellement d'accord sur tout mon père
ah bon et alors vous conformer au bout
de votre mère ah non non je fais la part
des choses un peu pour moi et puis un
peu pauvre c'est important d'être
élégant pour vous oui très important se
complaire lancé contre lui bon certes un
peu comme les autres puis ces lettres
modernes n'ont pas pu qui colle à la
taille mais la loterie nos valeurs
révélant sa gêne également ça qu'on
voulait sa mort certainement très bien
madame c'est vous qui conseiller votre
pays dans ses achats depuis maintenant 2
c et pitau et qui me conseille et vous
suivez ces conseils bien souvent très
souvent ils sont judicieux
oh oui faute schiste c'était important
pour vous de porter ce que vous aviez
envie oui pour quelle raison parce que
j'ai pas je me mets beaucoup plus policé
vêtements la queue avec d'autres il vous
est arrivé de refuser de porter ce que
votre mère vous avez acheté ou le
portera peut pas de refuser mais enfin
de porter très peu qui te faire un trou
ont pu le porter monsieur vous mettez
combien de temps général pour choisir
les cravates très longtemps c'est à dire
je sais pas parfois une demi-heure une
heure trop souvent des gravats peu à
fond vert pour quelle raison parce que
je le fond des yeux verts et ce manteau
ce joli manteau que vous portez sur vous
avez mis combien de temps pour choisir
à peine deux minutes les jeux les
décrocher je vais essayer m'a plu
d'abord j'ai vu comme ça c'est le coup
de foudre
le coup de foudre pour quelles raisons
expliquées masques aux poudres
la forme j'ai vu sur un cintre j'ai
pensé qu'il irait bien j'ai trouvé ça
magnifique les épaulettes le style
officier très simple très très près du
corps c'est le seul militaire qui font
l'effort militaire supérieur oui officié
sur surtout si anglet s'apprêterait à
bon ça faisait très anglais comme vous
aimez la mode anglaise beaucoup je ne
reçois un bis en angleterre et si cette
ligne style anglais nouvel élan c était
répandue dans tout paris est ce que vous
l'auriez adopté aussi facilement
oh non et s'il fallait une preuve que
s'habiller bien devenu pour la jeunesse
un véritable jeu nous l'aurions trouvez
au marché de saint-ouen ce marché aux
puces est devenu le lieu de rendez vous
d'un grand nombre de jeunes parisiens de
toutes conditions sociales à la
recherche du vêtement amusant bizarre
parfois excentrique et surtout pas cher
c'est même une étrange idée que tu as
payé chez avery pied opus vous appuyez
souvent la maison allait sortir
c'est à dire mais vous vous habillez
chez vous ah oui oui je peux recevoir
des amis louent ou non font plaisir
personnel
et comment vous habillez vous alors
ensuite 1925 pour quelle raison le style
est ce que j'aime beaucoup 225
j'aime beaucoup les gens filiforme je
trouve que c'est très stricte
vous préférez l'âme à 19,125 à la mode
actuelle j'aime la mode actuelle mais
comme je ne peux pas financièrement et
n'oubliez pas que c'est au marché aux
puces qu'est née la mode décapant des
vrais caban qui sentent encore l'odeur
de la mer quelle aventure compte il de
particulier vos cabas madame parce que
c'est très chaud vous savez ils sont
très pratiques et céder sur tout c'est
parce que ces américains
ce sont des vrais le nom de du marin qui
l'a porté oui et c'est très important
pour les gens vous avez en bonne
occasion ils sont très très long c'est
pourquoi voudriez vous savez les boutons
d'origine c'est ça son peu qu'ils
regardent les jeunes regardent sont tous
les boutons allons ses boutons c'est la
preuve que le cadran est d'origine et
ses blousons que j'aperçois double
écoute on est ce que vous les vendez aux
jeunes également
pas spécialement
pour les ouvriers vous savez pour les
motos font de la moto pour le froid pour
les chevriers 6 avril les étudiants
n'achète pas généralement non ceux qui
achètent le cabba n'achète pas les
boutons c'est très très rare
c'est très rare mais modèle êtes au
marché de saint-ouen que vous vous
habillez souvent un petit peu qu'est ce
que vous achetez au marché de saint-ouen
on achète les cirés ces pratiques et les
choses américaine quand on fire et vous
avez porté les choses américains les
vêtements américain oui mais si amusant
que c'est nous on est on est dans une
école où on a beaucoup plus ou moins une
chose comme ça va 100 ça lit beaucoup
mais mademoiselle les choses américaine
on peut les acheter ailleurs qu'au
marché de saint-ouen pourquoi mener bois
saint thois en on vous voulez vous les
achetez non non et non
c'est amusant ici à la nuit tombée c'est
le côté pittoresque qui vous est si mais
ça ne vous gêne pas de porter des choses
que d'autres ont déjà porté ça dépend
évidemment si c'est un pantalon c'est
embêtant mais quand c'est un manteau
et vous dépenser beaucoup d'argent puces
au finalement que j'ai vu quand on vient
on dépense que là je ferais tout ce
qu'on a sur soi on pourra se tenir
c'est à dire combien c'est l'époque qui
veut ça c'est 300 franquiste fallu dix
amis vous dépenser presque autant
d'argent que dans les grands magasins et
vos parents sont d'accord quand vous
vous habillez opus à moitié j'en ai
peut-être pour toi si tu as besoin on
dit pas ça en dix sept matches caen mais
les gars je suis relancé
vous portez tous les deux des pièces de
cuir noir pour quelle raison parce que
c'est la mode selamat oublie souvent
vous habille au marché de saint-ouen
souvent pour quelles raisons un peu
débordé surtout eu un succès moins cher
ya des nouveautés vous êtes après tout
elle court après toutes les nouveautés
surtout oui et pourquoi cibler vous
parce que vous pouvez
on peut marchander on peut trouver qu
est ce qu on veut tout ça qu'est-ce que
vous êtes venu acheter vos aujourd'hui
parlons d'un pantalon à l'antenne un
pantalon tube qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un pantalon iggy pop droite avec
dire sans revers en bas et c'est
important à ces indices étant de porter
des pantalons tube il faut suivre comme
le mouvement quoi pour quelles raisons
pour plaire surtout les rats qui doit
faire et vous mademoiselle vous faites
souvent dh en marché de saint-ouen oui
ils ont fait souvent pour quelle raison
parce que c'est pas cher il ya beaucoup
de gars très jolies choses qu'on ne
trouve pas de dossiers chauds les choses
ailleurs c'est à dire que je sortis
surtout des affaires assez moderne
trouve pas non maintenant quel quartier
un peu excentré oui cestas
découvrez-vous la mode et bien saoulé
les pages de journaux et dans les clubs
les clubs où vous allez danser vie et au
cinéma
non non vous ne rêvez pas donc d'être
habillé comme brigitte bardot ah non pas
du tout et comme vous êtes avec des bas
blancs des chaussettes blanches pull
étroitement qui colle un vêtement blanc
très maquillée vous plaisait
ah oui mais je me plais vous plaisait
aux autres quant à tout le monde
acquis des plaisait vous ai bien aux
garçons aux gens tout d'abord les gens
sortiront sur moi dans la rue m'enfin ça
me fait rire est un garçon garçon qui ne
sont pas moderne n'aime pas du tout ce
genre
[Musique]